so we've been given some information
about these three triangles here and
then they say use one of the triangles
so use one of these three triangles to
approximate the ratio the ratio is the
length of segment P n divided by the
length of segment MN so they want us to
figure out the ratio P n over m n so
pause this video and see if you can
figure this out all right now let's work
through this together now given that
they want us to figure out this ratio
and they want us to actually evaluate it
or be able to approximate it we are
probably dealing with a similarity and
so what I would want to look for is our
one of these triangles similar to the
triangle we have here and we're dealing
with similar triangles if we have two
angles in common because if we have two
angles in common then that means that we
definitely have the third angle as well
because the third angle is completely
determined by what the other two angles
are so we have a 35 degree angle here
and we have a 90 degree angle here and
of all of these choices this doesn't
have a 35 degree angle has a 90 this
doesn't have a 35 has a 90 but triangle
to here has a 35 degree angle has a 90
degree angle and has a 55 degree angle
and if you did the math knowing that 35
plus 90 Plus this have to add up to 180
degrees you would see that this 2 has a
measure of 55 degrees and so given that
all of our angle measures are the same
between triangle pnm and triangle number
two right over here we know that these
two are similar triangles and so the
ratios between corresponding sides are
going to be the same we could either
take the ratio across triangles or we
could say the ratio within when we just
look at one triangle and so if you look
at P n over m n let me try to color code
it so P n right over here that
corresponds to the side that's opposite
the 35 degree angle so that would
correspond to this side right over here
on triangle 2 and then MN that's this
that I'm coloring in this bluish color
not so well I've probably spent more
time coloring that's open that's
opposite the 55 degree angle
and so opposite the 55 degree angle
would be right over there
now since these triangles are similar
the ratio of the red side oh the length
of the red side over the length of the
blue side is going to be the same in
either triangle so P n let me write it
this way say the length of segment P n
over this length of segment m n is going
to be equivalent to five point seven
over eight point two because this ratio
is going to be the same for the
corresponding sides the regardless of
which triangle you look at so if you
take the side that's opposite 35 degrees
that's five point seven over eight point
two now to be very clear it doesn't mean
that somehow the length of this side is
five point seven or that the length of
this side is eight point two we would
only be able to make that conclusion if
they were congruent but with similarity
we know that the ratios if we if we look
at the ratio of the red side to the blue
side on each of those triangles that
would be the same and so this gives us
that ratio and let's see five point
seven over eight point two which of
these choices get close to that well we
could say that this is roughly if I am
approximating it let's see it's going to
be larger than zero point five seven
because eight point two is less than ten
and so we are going to rule this choice
out and five point seven is less than
eight point two so it can't be over one
and so we have to think between these
two choices well the simplest thing I
can do is actually just try to start
dividing it by hand so eight point two
goes into five point seven the same
number of times as 82 goes into 57 and
I'll add some decimals here so it
doesn't go into 57 but how many times
does 82 go into five hundred and seventy
I would assume it's about six times
maybe seven times
looks like so 7 times 2 is 14 and then 7
times 8 is 56 because it's 57 so it's
actually a little less than 0.7 this got
made me go a little bit too high
so if I am approximating it's going to
be 0.6 something so I like choice B
right over there